people always tell us that young people
are going to save the world
but there is simply not enough time to
wait
but fallout from climate change the
impacts could be catastrophic all of
this with the global warming
it's a hoax it is the most pressing
issue of our time
you have to go to school
when it came to the climate crisis i saw
my parents were just like everyone else
we weren't doing enough for many years
people refused to listen to me
children were very mean but i don't care
about being popular
i care about climate justice she felt
she had to do something and she had to
do it on her own
is climate change an issue that children
like yourself should be concerned about
you suffer from asperger syndrome i
would say suffer from but i have it
when i get interested in the subject i
become
laser focused there's a real movement
that's growing
greta comes up on stage she speaks and
her words
are devastating my name is krista timbe
and i want you to panic
we are in the midst of a mass extinction
time is running out
i can't just sit there and watch her do
all this for the environment
and do nothing
striking until they do something we
don't want to
burn out i think you should especially
be really careful i have been
invited to the united nations and since
i don't fly it's going to be a challenge
this is all wrong
i should be back in school on the other
side of the ocean
what we are doing now future generations
can't change
despite all the beautiful words and
promises our political leaders have
failed us
some people are so arrogant who think
they can change climate she faces a
really really tough eternity nothing is
happening so we must do what we can
we will not stop until we are done
you read a lot on climate a lot i'm a
[Laughter]
nerd
you